just like with any concept in organic
chemistry to demonstrate true
understanding we need to be able to
solve practice problems so that's what
we're going to do in this lesson to make
this kind of interesting and fun I've
chosen for drug molecules that we can
target the first one is per panel all
this is a beta blocker used to treat
high blood pressure and irregular heart
rate it's also sold under the name
inderal why don't you take a minute and
look at this molecule pause me and think
about the disconnections that you would
propose and if you can't get very far at
least try to make your first
disconnection let me show you how I
approach this cleaving adjacent to a
functional group is always a good idea
and we can cleave this bond right next
to the nitrogen and add the nitrogen
atom in somehow if we make this
disconnection we'll come up with two
synth ons so just drawing this at our
cleavage point without adding anything
in we'll get these fragments now
nitrogen is often a nucleophile so it
makes sense to make this the donor synth
on and put a negative charge on nitrogen
okay bearing in mind things from our
previous lessons nitrogen can over
alkylate under certain circumstances and
so it's a good idea to use reductive
amination or a mid formation to arrive
at the amine so if we're thinking about
this piece instead of just making this a
synth on we might think about what we
could have on there that would allow for
reductive amination to occur or a mid
formation to occur and this would be a
carbonyl we require a carbonyl to do
both of those reactions so let's add
that on now I'm not sure if this will be
an aldehyde or an ester so I'm just
gonna place an R group right there now
I'm leaving this undefined because I
haven't broken up the molecule
completely yet so I'm not really sure
what a good commercially available
compound is going to be for this so I'm
gonna leave my R group on there but make
my next disconnection boy oxygen and
oxygen in a 1:2 relationship
that looks like a great Epoque side
opening reaction let's assume this part
will be the nucleophile we don't want to
cleave next to the aromatic ring so if
we cleave on this side of the oxygen we
could get an epoxy ID from this piece
now I'm gonna skip the whole synth on
thing here when I cleave this obviously
looks like it's going to be the molecule
one naphthol so we can skip putting a
negative charge on this oxygen and go
straight to the reagent if we're seeing
that easily retrosynthesis is just a
tool for you to be able to write forward
syntheses and so whatever steps you need
to take take them and if you can skip a
step go ahead and do that as well
remember when we look at this we see the
positive charge next to an oxygen and if
we imagine the lone pair donating in
there we will be able to visualize our
Epoque side let me draw that now so I
have to admit in my time in the lab I've
never used an epoxy ID with an adjacent
carbonyl like this so I needed to go
ahead and look this up to see if these
types of compounds were even
commercially available and then to
determine how they react so let's go to
the web and do a little research so my
main concern in using an epoxy with a
carbonyl on it is how is it going to
react is the epoxy side going to open
does the carbonyl react
I just don't know much about the
reactivity so we'll go to the
sigma-aldrich structure search page and
we'll draw in our epoxy door as much as
we know of the structure that we want
we'll add in our oxygen atoms we know we
want the Epoque side and some carbonyl
over here we'll do a substructure search
because we really don't know exactly
what we want yet and this will give us
some hits and the most interesting thing
to me is the ester is commercially
available so I want to get its common
name so I can do this quick info thing
and copy that and then I'm gonna go over
to Google scholars so I can figure out
does this thing open up at the Epoque
side or does it react at the ester first
that's gonna be really important for
designing our synthesis in Google
Scholar I'm gonna paste our name
I'm gonna take out this 2r that has to
do with stereochemistry and I don't
really care which enantiomer I get and I
want this in a synthesis so I added the
word synthesis to my search now I can
scroll down and I don't want to make it
I want to see it used in a synthesis and
this one looks promising it also has a
PDF available when we go to this paper
the first table contains the reaction we
want above it and we can see here that
entry 6 actually has our ester and it's
produced in really good yield
this opens the Epoque side leaving the
ester on the molecule so we have
precedent to open our POC side and leave
our ester in place well now with that
information and this precedent we can go
back to our synthesis now that we have
precedent for phenols or a nap fall here
opening up Epoque sides at this carbon
atom and preserving the ester we can go
ahead and write up this reaction that
precedent was using a pretty fancy
catalyst and they were doing a nante O
selective process so that catalyst was
making one single chiral compound coming
out we probably don't need to do that
for this synthesis because we don't have
any requirement to have stereochemistry
defined at any of our carbon atoms but
we'll go ahead and just write catalyst
we might be able to find some simpler
conditions and make a racemic mixture of
this alcohol so the chiral Center I was
referring to could be right here so we
could make this enantiopure if we wanted
to based on the precedent we found but
we don't have to for this problem so
this is a chiral carbon right here okay
our final stage involves condensing this
with some sort of an amine and so here
we're going to have the amine form our
amide and then we're going to reduce
that amat with lah the first compound we
need is the amine corresponding to this
synth on then we're going to reduce it
with lithium aluminum hydride here I've
written laa
li al h4 is the other way to write that
this is just a very common abbreviation
and after using this hydride donor we're
going to need to find a way to
neutralize any of it left in solution
and work it up so now we have our
synthesis outlined we have a few things
that are kind of missing details here
but we can go to the literature and find
good precedent if we are really going to
make these molecules and actually do
these synthesis in the lab we would need
to look up conditions and molar
equivalents of things used but here we
have a quite a good outline for how we
would carry this out so how did our
synthesis compare to the way that they
actually make propanolol this is a known
drug they make it a lot let's check out
their synthesis and compare we'll learn
a few things from this in commercial
production they actually use a different
Epoque side this one containing a
chloride leaving group and in the patent
they claim that they isolate this Epoque
side from it so an sn2 reaction occurs
with this chloride or the epoxy opens
and closes back down it's kind of hard
to know the mechanism since in the
patent just this compound is reported
then they open this epoxy side by direct
treatment with an amine you might be
concerned about over alkylation but
actually the reaction of a means to open
Epoque sides this is quite a good
reaction in addition the isopropyl group
on the amine makes the product quite
sterically hindered so all they ended up
doing was adding this amine heating up
the mixture and presumably it opens the
up oxide on the least sterically
hindered side and we got pro Pennell all
from this let's apply what we've learned
to the synthesis of another drug prior
cane this is a local anesthetic why
don't you go ahead and pause me and see
if you can propose some disconnections
for this molecule okay one thing we
should notice we have a nitrogen with an
isopropyl again and this molecule looks
pretty hindered too so we may just be
able to use what we learned in a last
example to put on this group as well
cleaving next to head
Adams's is always a good idea and so
let's go ahead and put two possible
disconnections onto this molecule here
I'm cleaving in the middle of the a
module called this disconnection a and
here I'm cleaving to the left of this
nitrogen and we'll call this B let's
examine the synth ons that would result
from each route and see if we can
determine a way to go with this let's
examine the synth ons that would result
from row a we have our nitrogen as our
donor synth on with the negative charge
here and then we have this carbonyl as
an acceptor putting a leaving group
right here would be a great way to go
and we could do an ester or even better
we could do something much more reactive
that's a more reliable way to form the
amat and that's the acid chloride let's
look at the sentence from route B okay
now our donor is this piece looking a
lot like isopropyl amine and we have
this acceptor synth on right here so
when we look at cleaving via route B we
have our donor synth on as our amine and
then we have this cation adjacent to a
carbonyl compound we saw in previous
videos that it's pretty straightforward
to install a halide next to a carbonyl
and so this is a pretty good synth on -
it's really not obvious to me here which
route we should choose so what I'm going
to do is cleave another bond and go back
one more step to see if I can make some
sense of this
so in this compound will cleave this
bond and let's just assume this is
coming from the acid chloride okay so
I've shown the acid chloride if I cleave
this bond I'll need a leaving group here
if I'm using the natural nucleophilicity
of this amine right here so it probably
makes sense to have two chlorides on the
molecule so we can envision this leaving
group maybe as another chloride and then
we have our amine let's go back one more
step with this one will cleave the amat
here and let's see what we get so
essentially our routes are pretty
similar they both come back to the same
compound so when we're deciding how to
make this we need to think about which
side of this molecule is more reactive
that
the acid chloride these are very
activated compounds so we're going to
want to add to this side way before we
do an sn2 displacement of this chlorine
let's see what that gives us for our
forward route because an acid chloride
wants to react at the carbonyl carbon
first we're going to choose this route
our forward synthesis becomes this so
first we'll get addition of our lamine
to this side of the molecule forming
this and now we just need to add in the
reagent corresponding to this sent on
this is isopropyl amine which we met in
our previous synthesis here the product
of alkylation is very sterically
hindered and so we can form this
directly by treating this compound with
the amine this forms this target
molecule which we'll call TM 2 so how
did our synthesis compare to the one
that's actually used well it's really
really close they actually use the
dibromide here so they use an acid
bromide with a bromine leaving group
probably because that facilitates this
step here with bromine being a better
leaving group and they just need to heat
that step up to get it to go next we're
going to look at this molecule this is
not low per a minute self but this is an
intermediate along the pathway to
synthesize it loperamide you might know
by the name imodium
this is an anti-diarrheal belonging to
the opioid class of drugs go ahead and
pause me and try to tackle this molecule
pay careful attention to the pattern of
the functional groups within the
molecule while you do this okay we might
be tempted like in previous examples to
cleave maybe here first next to this
nitrogen well we don't want to cleave
off this group last that would leave us
with an amine in NH and amines in the
presence of carbonyl compounds can
undergo various reactions so it's
probably best to leave this intact what
I'm noticing in this molecule is this 1
3 dicarbonyl compound and dycar
compounds can be formed quite readily
from the claisen reaction if you didn't
think about that go ahead and pause me
again and see if you can propose the
disconnection now we'll have to place
our disconnection here that's because in
the claisen reaction the side that
retains the ester is the side that
analyzed let's draw our synth ons so we
have this side analyzing and acting as a
nucleophile
we need this positive character here so
a way we could introduce that is by
putting on a leaving group and it makes
sense to have the leaving group match
this side since it's a claisen reaction
and we usually use a base that matches
the ester so our starting reagent would
be this there's some nice symmetry going
on in this molecule here and we notice
our groups are nitrogen and oxygen
groups now are in a 1 2 3 a 1 3
relationship
now let's cleave a bond next to our
nitrogen and draw our synth ons in a
previous video we looked at something
like this and the reagent that can
correspond to this can be the e known
and as long as this undergoes a
conjugate addition with our n own we'll
get this pattern so we can envision this
coming from this reagent now hopefully
you're noticing that this side is
symmetrical and we could just do this by
an analogous reaction so this would be
our disconnection and for this side this
would be our starting material again
let's skip straight to our forward
synthesis benzyl amine an inexpensive
commercially available compound can
react with 2 molecules of this to give
this intermediate treatment of this now
with sodium ethoxide we'll analyze one
side displacing the group from the other
and that will directly give us this
which we'll call target molecule 3 wow
so we took what looked like a pretty
complex molecule with three functional
groups in it and we were able to just
make it in two steps before our final
retrosynthesis I want to just do a
little bit of an aside on the manic
reaction this is another reaction
that'll put
nitrogen and oxygen in a 1:3
relationship and I left it out of an
earlier video thinking it was kind of
complex because it's a multi-component
reaction but I think we're ready for it
now and then maybe we can apply it in an
example this manic product comes from
three starting materials we have an
amine a secondary amine a non enolizable
substrate here and then an enol izybelle
carbonyl compound as well this partner
is often from aldehyde let's do a little
abbreviated mechanism to understand
what's going on here so these three
components are going to react in the
presence of catalytic acid so in this
first step we're gonna have the amine
react with the non enolizable carbonyl
compound which is in the presence of
acids so this will be protonated the
amine can attack at this carbon
and we'll get this intermediate a proton
transfer will put this hydrogen onto the
oxygen
now nitrogen can kick out the water with
its lone pair of electrons forming an
iminium ion don't forget we still have
an enol izybelle substrate in the mix
under acidic conditions this will form
an enol this enol can attack the carbon
atom pushing the electrons back onto
nitrogen giving it back its lone pair
and neutralizing this positive charge so
let's show that arrow pushing these
electrons come down these will go onto
this carbon atom and nitrogen becomes
neutral again and we get our ketone and
our amine in a 1:3 relationship
keeping this reaction in mind see if you
can come up with a synthesis of this
anti parkinson drug now if you can't
apply the manic reaction no worries it's
just important that you can get back to
commercially available compounds but if
you can't apply the manic reaction that
would be pretty cool too okay well the
manic reaction begins with an enol
izybelle ketone here and we don't have
that in this molecule but we do have an
alcohol with two groups added to it and
this just screams grignard so we can add
grignard of either of these pieces to a
carbonyl compound and arrive at an
alcohol so it makes sense that we cleave
one of these bonds if we're going to
apply the manic reaction so which do we
want to cleave so it's the last step do
we want to take off this cyclohexyl or
the phenol both of these are available
as grignard reagents so we have
cyclohexyl magnesium bromide and phenol
magnesium bromide and we can buy both of
them now remember when we're analyzing
this one was a good example because it's
symmetrical so it doesn't matter which
side enol eise's so if something over
here is going to come from a ketone well
we want it to only be able to analyze on
one side a phenyl ring is not enolizable
it's sp2 Center right there and so it
really makes sense to cleave this bond
first and I'm going to take this
straight back to the starting materials
and not the sentence this is kind of
flipped over but it is so similar to
this molecule here so we can put in our
disconnections we're actually going to
have a couple when we're applying the
manic reaction there'll be this part
coming from an enolate that corresponds
to this this carbon here comes from
formaldehyde and then this comes from
our amine
this is benzophenone formaldehyde and
piperidine and these are all
commercially available let's finish off
with our forward synthesis mixing these
three components with catalytic HCl will
give us this adding our grignard will
make an alkoxide and then we'll need a
workup step and let's call our anti
Parkinson's drug target molecule for
thanks for sticking with me to the end
and I just want to point out that you've
worked on the synthesis of four drug
molecules you medicinal chemist you and
so I hope you feel empowered to be able
to look at important molecules and drugs
and start to pick apart the bonds a
little bit and think about how somebody
might make them great work KP here if
you learn something give me a thumbs up
on the way out and for more chemistry
subscribe to my channel